m
bah
bienvenue sur le trou numéro 2 donc trop
numéro 2 qui va
point de cours à ses stratégies
également à jouer pour pour les pour les
joueurs la ryder cup pourquoi parce que
c'est un trou qui techniquement est
assez compliqué c'était un trou sur
lequel si le joueur a mal engagé le trou
numéro 1 un peu ce vide se mettre la
pression sur ce trou numéro 2 6 langage
mal ce trou numéro 2 peut vite se mettre
la pression pour la suite la suite du
tournoi
être numéro 2 qui était en par trois qui
fait 192 mètres de 110 yards avec comme
point loire la plus grosse difficulté
qui est à
abello l'obstacle d'eau qui est vraiment
on va dire plus que présente devant le
green et surtout pas ce green qui a
encore une fois un peu similaire à ce
trou numéro un est un homme green qui
est plutôt dans la largeur est assez peu
dans la profondeur donc là vraiment la
difficulté ça sera la foule
encore une fois qui sera certainement
assez nombreuse autour de ceux de ce
coup là parce que là la priorité c'est
de trouver et de faire le bon choix du
club parce que il faut quand même posé
une balle avec énormément de pression à
plus de 190 m
avec la punition qui est immédiate si le
coup est mal touché où le club trop
court même trop long parce que quand on
peut le voir au fond derrière il ya
quand même dur est fait des bunkers qui
accueilleront les balles avec grand
plaisir
[Musique]
donc là on est sur le green du trou
numéro 2 donc ça va être quoi c'est
spectaculaire parce que ça reste du
match play et donc le match v aura
différentes stratégies soient les
joueurs qui vont être beaucoup dans
l'offensive qui vont attaquer tous les
bas soit plus tôt on va dire dans une
stratégie plutôt d'attentes mais il
n'empêche que le drapeau au fond à
gauche sera prêt délicat et l'autre
position également qui est extrêmement
délicate
c'est à l'entrée à droite parce que là
vraiment la zone sur laquelle le joueur
peut poser la balle est vraiment je sais
pas et d'ailleurs à peu près 3 4 mètres
de profondeur et si il est en dehors
serre que s'il a un coup à jouer du
bunker en quoi jouer du rock ou si le
courrier est mal touché avec une balle
trop courte
tout de suite le joueur est délicat donc
trou numéro 2 on est toujours dans
l'arène de l'est pas et je pense que sur
ces deux trous qu'on a vu trop de meuron
un trou numéro deux il m'a se passer
beaucoup de choses à la fin du mois